like it was weird I would I asked them
2022 name one thing that is holding
women back in 2022 and they'd be like
well well you're privileged and I'm like
yeah okay okay and Andy I get it I'm
privileged and and then they'd be like
well like one girl didn't have legs and
she'd be like well I'm disabled I don't
have legs and I'm like well what does
that have to do with women like most
women have legs I'm sorry yeah you
didn't get the right lot in life
that's like a you not a women thing and
then they're like well I'm a refugee
this girl's like I'm just like okay you
came here when you're like four it's not
the same thing as like
okay
um I'm like okay but women like most
women aren't refugees and then it was so
funny I'm like name one name one thing
and then there's like the pay Gap and
I'm like well women don't want to do the
hard jobs and then they're like well you
keep talking about women like do you
hate do you hate women and I'm just like
I am a woman